c'était il ya très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il ya eu le ciel au
milieu du ciel il y avait la terre et
sur la terre il n'y avait rien ou
presque rien
la population de la terre comptait
quelques bestioles pas très réussis
comme le gorille vu le lapin poisson et
le minet qu'entre up espèces étaient en
voie de disparition rapide plus
certaines insectes d'une eau de gégène
et qu'ils n'avaient pas l'intention de
disparaître comme nous le verrons tard à
gauche du ciel il y avait des shadoks et
la fusée shadoks à droite du ciel il y
avait les gy be et la fusée jbe
comme nos téléspectateurs le savent
l'egypte y avait un petit chapeau sur la
tête et c'était là le secret de leur
intelligence quand un jbe réfléchissait
à quelque chose d'un peu compliqué hop
il mettait ça dans son chapeau sa passe
est automatiquement dans les autres
chapeaux et tous les gimmicks mettait à
réfléchir ensemble sans qu'on ait besoin
de leur explique pour la nourriture
il n'avait pas de problème non plus il y
avait des gibiers à pain des libyens
lait et des gibiers un fromage c'est
dire que pour aller sur une planète même
lointaine l'egypte ils n'avaient pas
besoin d'en porter autre chose que leur
chapeau